by now we've all seen the horrifying
pictures of russia's torture and murder
in ukraine putin's war crimes are so
grotesque they require of the united
states i think a tougher sharper more
lethal response that's certainly the way
the actor sean penn sees it after
spending time at the front lines in
ukraine even as putin launched his
murderous invasion speaking with our
sean hannity last night penn revealing
what it was like to be with ukraine's
heroic president zielinski in those
gripping moments
he is the face of something that you see
in all the ukrainians we saw and talked
to this extraordinary courage that's
come up and he it was in his eyes and
it is clear to me that the ukrainians
will win this the question is at what
cost we can get f-15s f-16s and then
they can fly those with three weeks of
training they can fly the migs in the
sus now and we know that from the
california national guard who has had a
30-year
exercise training
mutual with with ukraine and we're there
with the ukrainian aviators just shortly
before they were pulled out because this
of the the politics
hence call for us to do more militarily
comes as america slaps more economic
sanctions on russia's two largest banks
on more of putin's oligarch cronies and
even on vlad's two daughters
now i know judge or i assume
maybe the road to hell steve with the
subject i assume that sean penn's not
your kind of guy but isn't he right here
well it doesn't matter if he's my kind
of guy i mean i i love seeing a liberal
you know at least come on fox and talk
about something that he knows something
about this isn't just someone at the
academy awards mouthing off about
politics i'm happy to listen to him he's
been there he's been on the ground he
knows of what he speaks so absolutely
yeah well i don't know if it took guts
he's gonna always took guts to go with
look i'm gonna take scott to go on the
view in some cases i mean you know he's
coming out sean's show saying what
people want to hear him say that's a
very important point we treat them well
when they come here
it's not the case when you go on the
view speaking of a good point i think
but speaking of how people are treated
should we be harder on pro-russia
commentators given the glaring evidence
that atrocities are being committed i
think that was a great tv moment
i thought it was amazing i i think it
bucked the illiberal trend of
condemnation by connection that you know
if you go on fox i can't you know i
can't talk to you anymore you went on
hannity and likewise even the viewers
look at him differently but there was
one thing he said geraldo that i thought
was pretty shocking because it came from
sean penn he said
even countries that have nuclear weapons
can remain intimidated to use them and
we are seeing that now within our own
country and i fear what that legacy is
going to be
now if you would have told me 10 years
ago that sean penn would be entertaining
the potential for using nuclear weapons
i would burn my vhs copy of shanghai
surprise i mean is it it's it's it's
another example of the flop it's uh or
the flip and so when you're talking
about pro-russian commentators you're
not seeing the kind of consistent
narrative you really want to see there
are people that are going to say things
that you don't like and it's not pr it's
not pro-russia to be anti-war so you
have to be very careful about how you
categorize people i have yet to meet a
pro-russia person there are some who are
in their in their narrative why not name
them well you're trying to make why
you're
doing your
geraldo you're subtweeting it it's not a
good look
well
meaning what
meaning you are you're sub tweeting
right now no i'm no i'm saying it right
to you
we have so many things on our plate with
immigration and inflation and so forth
can the american people stay focused on
ukraine dana
well i think that's probably zielinski's
concern right that the west will tire of
this um that we have a lot of things
that we have to deal with but america
can do that that wasn't that america
always does that and i thought that
linda thomas greenfield the ambassador
our ambassador to the u.n did a really
strong job yesterday and then as to sean
penn i love it when sean hannity does
these interviews because it gives you a
chance to just sit back
and he doesn't
periodically and there's always somebody
different you get a lot of eyeballs and
then you have somebody like sean pan
who's he was there he saw it and a lot
of people around the world are wondering
how does this guy go from being an actor
and a comedian and then he like becomes
this
leader that everybody wants to know
about he has a 77 approval rating around
the world i don't know if that lasts uh
in terms of zelinski but he really has
captured the imagination and sean penn
was there to see it and then told us
about it i i think champion did an
excellent job should we give f-16s to
ukraine it's getting close to that the
tanks are already there and if they move
this war away to the east and the
russian forces are being degraded pretty
heavily there's going to be a lot of
people uh on both sides of the aisle
talking about the mig transfer i liked
how they opened the interview and sean
said when i called you what was the
first thing you said to me and sean penn
says i said i didn't trust you
and it was great because then he said
and so what mistrust is petty we're
talking about war and peace here and
another takeaway besides the fact that
he thinks ukrainians are going to win
was that when you go over there and he
said you see the ukrainians united as a
country as one
it made him kind of sad that the united
states is not like that and he wishes we
could get to that point at some point um
soon because that's something we need
well i i think that the
march toward escalation will be
inexorable because we cannot as the
american people withstand shots of
people's heads blown off and murders of
children and raping women and this is
this is real we can't avoid our glance
yeah we got joe biden there so who knows
what do you mean
joe doesn't want that's more subtexting
flying is already excruciatingly bad now
the cost of your airplane ticket is
about to soar
details next hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else